wir machen Spaghettieis mit Erdbeersoße
und weißer Schokolade und das ist
verdammt lecker und hier ist alles was
wir brauchen wir haben einmal Milch
Schlagsahne Zucker eine Vanilleschote
Eigelb und für später weiße Schokolade
und Erdbeeren jetzt halbiere ich die
Vanilleschote und kratze sie einmal aus
wir haben jetzt Zucker die Schote und
das mag drin kochen ist einmal aufnehmen
eine Schüssel und gebe sechs Eigelb
hinein dazu der restliche Zucker und das
ganze verrühre ich jetzt zu einer Masse
denn die Vanille Milch wieder aufgekocht
ist rühren wir sie langsam unter unserer
Eigel über dem Wasserbad rühren wir
jetzt die Sahne Mischung bis sie dick
wird in die Masse so dickflüssig ist die
kalte Schlagsahne unterrühren sobald die
drin ist setzen wir sie hier in unser
Eisbad und rühren das ganze kalt jetzt
holen wir die Eismaschine und füllen die
gekühlte Masse durch das Sieb ein Deckel
drauf und hier können wir uns um die
Erdbeersoße nehmen wir uns unsere
Erdbeeren und geben sie in den Topf
jetzt pürieren wir unsere Erdbeeren
jetzt machen wir den Herd an lassen die
warm werden und rühren bisschen Zucker
rein jetzt gehen wir die Eismasse noch
für 20 Minuten in die Gefriertruhe jetzt
fehlt uns nur noch etwas Sahne auf dem
Teller denn